[Musique]
lequel laquelle d'entre nous n'a pas
déjà essayé d'échapper à son nombre de
lutter contre un fantôme un souvenir
douloureux du passé
une appréhension quant à l'avenir une
peur une anxiété dont on ne connaît
peut-être même pas la cause et si c'est
le cas vous avez certainement remarqué
que les ombres comme le fantôme court
toujours
au moins aussi rapidement que nous je
suis chercheur en psychologie
docteur en psychologie spécialisé dans
le domaine des émotions et lorsqu'on
s'intéresse au sujet on constate que la
lutte et la fuite sont deux réactions
déclenchées par tout système d'alarmé
émotionnel tout au long de l'histoire de
l'évolution
elles nous ont permis d'échapper aux
prédateurs le contrôle et
l'environnement en bref de survivre et
cela a tellement bien fonctionné puisque
vous et moi nous sommes là aujourd'hui
que nous tentons d'appliquer les mêmes
vieilles recettes aux menaces qui nous
semblent venir de l'intérieur
nos propres émotions difficiles nous
avons peur de notre peur et entendra
supprimés nous sommes en colère contre
notre jalousie et faisons tout pour nous
en débarrasser
nous avons honte notre tristesse
essayons de la cacher cela me rappelle
ma dernière fête des voisins c'est moi
qui invitait et j'avais fais passer le
mot à tout le voisinage est mis sur le
fronton de ma porte dessus une belle
banderole sur laquelle était écrit
bienvenue à tous et à toutes
c'était une très belle soirée d'été et
tout allait bien jusqu'au moment où je
me suis rappelé d'albert albert c'est un
peu le mouton noir du bloc
il vit dans la rue près du supermarché
et se promène toujours avec son chien
plein de puces qui sont aussi mauvais
que lui il parle très fort il est
agressif désagréable
et s'il lui venait l' envie de venir à
ma fête
et j'ai bien écrit bienvenue à tous et à
toutes me voilà tout d'un coup pris
d'une anxiété
je me lève je vais vers la porte pour
les décrocher la banderole est alors que
je m'en approche
cela sonne et au travers de la vitre
translucide
je devine la silhouette massive d'albert
je sens son parfum nauséabond
albert dans mon histoire ce sont toutes
les émotions que nous n'aimons pas celle
dont nous voulons nous débarrasser la
peur la colère la tristesse la jalousie
longtemps dans ma vie j'ai tourné le dos
à la porte et fait comme si de rien
n'était mais ce que cela fonctionne à
long terme
ce jour là ce n'est pas une petite peur
c'est une anxiété écrasante albert
tambourine sur la porte je n'ouvre pas
alors il va décrocher la porte il rentre
en force
je vais alors essayé ma deuxième
stratégie contrôler et surveiller albert
afin qu'ils ne s'aiment pas la pagaille
dans ma fête
mais imaginez si je passe mes soirées
accroché aux basques de l'invité
indésirable pour l'empêcher de faire une
bêtise quelle disponibilité me
reste-t-il à accorder aux autres invités
la joie le contentement la gratitude la
gaieté l' enthousiasme à ce propos
j'aime beaucoup la phrase de maître
eckhart dieu nous rend souvent visite
le seul problème c'est que nous sommes
rarement à la maison
nous sommes nous pas prisonnier de tout
ce que nous refusons de tout ce contre
quoi nous luttons dans la mesure même de
l'énergie que nous mettons à lutter et à
refuser mais le problème c'est que
lorsque l'on a appris à lutter on pense
que c'est la seule solution est la
meilleure et on ne se rend pas compte du
prix à payer lorsque j'avais 16 ans
j'habitais dans le sud de la france
et ma mère était en belgique pour se
faire soigner d'un cancer bien sûr je
savais que le cancer est une maladie
terrible mais je ne me rendais pas
compte à quel point cela pouvait aller
vite et le groupement dans lequel je
vivais qui voulait faire le bien des
autres à leur insu ne me tenez pas
informés et une nuits on met dans une
voiture on me dit il y'as doit partir
vite et douze heures après en descendant
du véhicule quelqu'un me regarde et me
dit ta mère vient de mourir
l'émotion qui m'a pris ce jour-là comme
elle me prend aujourd'hui a été
tellement immense que je n'ai pas pu y
faire face et la personne qui en a payé
le prix
c'est ma soeur elle aurait eu tellement
besoin de quelqu'un pour la comprendre
pour l'écouter pour partager sa peine
mais moi incapable que j'étais de
prendre soin de mes propres sentiments
bien sûr que je n'ai pas pu prendre soin
d'elle cela mettait tout bonnement
impossible alors évidemment que nous
pouvons gagner la bataille contre
quelque chose d'extérieur
mais lorsque la lutte se fait contre nos
propres émotions
nous perdons toujours quel autre
attitude pourrions-nous adopté
si vous êtes un jour pris dans des
sables mouvants votre réaction
automatique sera certainement la lutte
est alors que vous tentez désespérément
2-1 de vos pieds vous mettez davantage
de pression sur l'autre jambe qui à son
tour s'enfonce
la solution simple et pourtant contre
intuitive consisterait à s'allonger de
tout son long sur le marais afin de
répartir son poids sur la plus grande
surface possible et peut-être éviter de
couler par rapport à nos propres
sentiments
cela revient à consentir à vivre nos
émotions difficiles afin de les
apprivoiser et de nous en libérer
revenons à mon histoire d'albert ce jour
là quand il sonne à la porte
je vais ouvrir directement je sais que
c'est lui ce n'est plus la première fois
que j'écoute mes sentiments bienvenue
albert
quelle drôle de tête tu as aujourd'hui
je l'emmène au buffet je le sers une
assiette
je m'installe confortablement bien sûr
ce n'est pas que je doive être d'accord
avec tout ce qu'il raconte
ni même que je doive l'aimé c'est
simplement que je sais que refuser n'est
pas une option viable que lutter contre
lui est plus dangereux qu accepter
alors une fois que j'en ai pris soin
j'ai toute ma disponibilité à accorder
aux autres invités
la joie la gratitude le contentement la
gaieté l'entousiasme la compassion notre
part de liberté ne réside-t-elle pas
dans notre capacité à prendre soin de
tous nos invités
même et surtout ceux qui sont
désagréables et que nous n'avons pas
convié
la recherche scientifique confirme
depuis longtemps les vertus des
attitudes d'acceptation et d'accueil
une équipe de chercheurs de l'université
de new york de boston a testé cette
proposition de manière expérimentale sur
un groupe de personnes souffrent
d'anxiété panique ils ont réparti les
participants en trois groupes un premier
à qui l'on propose est d'éviter de fuir
d'essayer de supprimer les émotions ce
que la plupart d'entre nous tente bien
souvent un deuxième à qui on ne donnait
pas d'instructions particulières à un
groupe de comparaison et enfin le
dernier à qui l'on avait enseigné à
accueillir et accepter les sensations
émotions désagréables
ensuite tous les participants à l'aide
d'un masque était exposé à de l'air
enrichi au co2 qui créent très
rapidement les symptômes d'une panique
importante avant de mesurer l'anxiété
ressenti ainsi que le degré de liberté
comportementale comment à la fin de
l'expérience ont demandé à chacun s'ils
seraient d'accord de revenir faire
l'expérience désagréable
sous prétexte que les mesures n'avaient
pas bien fonctionné de manière très
intéressante
c'étaient les participants qui
acceptaient le ressentiment qui était
qui rapportaient avoir le moins
d'anxiété et c'est aussi cela qui était
davantage d'accords de revenir
on pourrait dire que comparé aux
participants des deux autres groupes
il était moins esclaves des conditions
émotions difficiles déclenchée par
l'expérience scientifique lutter contre
nos émotions
on le voit ne fonctionne pas mais le
pire c'est que lorsque nous sommes
habitués à lutter et à éviter le
sentiment nous finissons par éviter
consciemment ou inconsciemment les
contextes situations dans lesquelles ces
sentiments pourrait se produire avec des
conséquences plus graves
nous n'allons pas nous engager dans un
projet important par peur d'échouer
nous n'irons pas vers quelqu'un qui
compte pour nous par peur d'être rejeté
nous n'ouvrirons pas nos bras à ce que
nous aimons par peur de souffrir notre
vie devient de plus en plus étriqué elle
se réduit mais une autre conséquence
c'est que refuser les sentiments c'est
aussi comme refuser notre boussole
intérieure nos émotions sont comme une
phase d'une pièce de monnaie
indissociable de l'autre face l'autre
face qui correspond à l'information sur
tout ce qui est important pour nous car
nous n'avons d'émotion difficile que
parce que c'est important
je suis anxieux pour la petite fille ou
pour un ami parce qu'ils comptent pour
moi je suis triste d'avoir perdu quelque
chose parce que cette chose était
importante
refuser d'être connecté mes sentiments
c'est comme refuser l'information sur
tout ce qui est essentiel dans ma vie et
duquel je devrais prendre soin bien sûr
nous aimerions tous avoir la baguette
magique qui supprime toutes les
difficultés de l'existence mais nous
savons qu'elle n'existe pas pour moi la
grande bascule de ma vie est arrivé le
jour j'ai compris qu'il me serait
impossible d'être libre de quoi que ce
soit centre par là-même automatiquement
prisonniers de la chose même de laquelle
je voulais me libérer que la
désobéissance la plus importante pour ma
liberté
c'était la désobéissance par rapport à
mes propres peurs mes propres
conditionnement si je suis timide et que
j'attends d'être libres 2 ma timidité
avant d'aller vers les autres
je pourrais attendre très longtemps et
ce jour peut-être n'arrivera jamais
n'est-il pas plus réaliste d'apprendre à
vivre avec ma timidité et ce jour là la
prendre en dessous d'un bras ma peur en
dessous de l'autre et avec elle deux
aller vers ce qui est important dans ma
vie mais cette forme de liberté là elle
a un prix entrée en amitié avec toutes
mes émotions
même les plus difficiles cela s'appelle
le courage à ce propos le poète rilke
que nous dit et si tous les dragons de
nos vies n'étaient que des princes et
des princesses qui attend de nous voir
heureux heureuse et courageux courageuse
du courage il m'en a fallu longtemps
après la mort de mes parents pour
retourner sur le pas de ma porte
intérieure et faire face à toutes les
émotions qui s'y trouvaient il a aussi
fallu du temps pour les apprivoiser pas
à pas comme le petit prince à
apprivoiser son renard et cette perte
qui était comme un fantôme que je
voulais tenir éloigné de moi s'est
transformé en une fleur dans mon jardin
intérieur
une flore que j'arrose parfois de
quelques larmes et qui me connecte notre
commune humanité
la bonne nouvelle pour celles et ceux
qui comme moi connaissent la peur c'est
que ce sont les seuls qui peuvent se
montrer courageux petit peur petit
courage grande peur grand courage pas de
peur pas de courage
la peur n'est donc pas un problème c'est
la peur de la peur qui nous paralyse
lorsque j'apprends à vivre avec tous les
invités de ma fête des voisins intérieur
je ne suis plus alors conditionnée à
réagir manière automatique et souvent
tout à fait inapproprié aux
circonstances émotions difficiles de la
vie mais je peux répondre de manière
libre et intelligente à la situation
telle qu'elle se présente
saviez vous que lorsque les vents
tourbillonnants d'un ouragan vont à plus
de 300 km heure l'endroit le plus calme
se trouve paradoxalement au coeur même
de la tornade
mais il ya les demandes du courage le
courage de cesser de fuir celui de faire
face à nos ombres et à nos fantômes pour
nous installer au coeur même de
l'expérience là dans l'oeil du cyclone
les vents ne font plus que que 30 km
heure il y règne un calme d'une d'une
étonnante beauté
c'est là que nous pouvons découvrir que
le cadeau de la peur c'est la tendresse
une infinie tendresse pour la vie merci
[Applaudissements]